the president Nintendo solve what you're
doing
the president of Nintendo
I just damn what the hell am I doing the
president said though I'm moving them to
the 21st Century Fox just if I just get
off like I listen and they can stick to
the way they sell games because it works
for them it just works for them I'm
Gonna Keep it a buck to me
I don't even worry so much about the
hardware man like it's just like
definitely definitely Hardware that
isn't just at the cusp of where they're
gonna make money because all they care
about is making money on the hardware
from the rip they don't they never want
to lose money on Hardware not even a
week so
at least be at the cusp of where
technology is right and beyond that sell
your games the way you want to sell them
don't be everywhere be closed off the
way you are because it works for you I
don't think if there's anything we've
learned about what Nintendo was
competing right once at once